في المقابل قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان
المدفعيه الروسيه استهدفت بضربات دقيقه
مواقع للقوات الاوكرانيه قرب باخمه شرقيه
اوكرانيا وبثت الوزاره صورا قالت انها
لتدمير مواقع تابعه للجيش الاوكراني في
محور بخموت هذا ولم تكشف الوزاره عن حصيله
الخسائر التي خلفتها تلك الضربات
كما نشرت وكاله الانباء الروسيه مقطع
فيديو قالت انه يوثق تدمير القوات المسلحه
الروسيه قوات الدعم التابعه للقوات
الاوكرانيه باستخدام قذيفه هون في اتجاه
كريسنو لمنسكي في دونيتسك وتظهر المشاهد
اطلاق القوات الروسيه قذائون باتجاه احد
الاهداف الاوكرانيه وقال المتحدث باسم
المجموعه القتاليه المركزيه الروسيه
الكسندر ساف تشوك ان وحدات المجموعه
القتاليه صدت هجومين اوكرانيين قرب منطقه
تورسكي وكبدت العدو خسائر بلغت نحو 60
جنديا